for the past couple years I've been
working on data science applications
using wolfram technology and most
recently in the cloud this talk is going
to consist almost entirely of examples
of doing data science in the cloud data
coming from a variety of sources in a
variety of domains it's more than we can
possibly talk about in 20 minutes in any
detail so my hope is that some of this
will be close to something that you are
working on and that you will seek me out
later so that we can have a more
in-depth conversation about how this
stuff might be able to help you the data
that we're going to be looking at is
going to be coming from plain old files
it's going to be coming from public API
is it's going to be coming from an
external services and it's also going to
going to going to be coming from
databases on the analysis side of things
i'll try to point out instances where
we're using relatively recent full
functionality that's been relatively
recently introduced like time series and
time series analysis and Geographics and
machine learning and then on the
publication side I'll I'll emphasize I
think the publication side of thing side
of things is the part that gets weirdest
when the cloud is introduced it has the
most new concepts in it and and I'll say
a bit about how computable documents
work in the cloud how do you how you
deploy them how notebook templating
works and about this Wolfram language
construct called the document generator
that ties all these things together okay
so let's jump right in let's get some
data from Instagram so I'm going to open
up a template notebook on my desktop
that is designed to pulling data from
Instagram and make a little report okay
so we're not in the cloud here we're
right in we're on my desktop this is a
template notebook it behaves just like a
normal Mathematica notebook except that
it has this toolbar at the top I'm going
to press this generate button and keep
jabbering while it's working the toolbar
at the top controls the behavior and
appearance of documents that are
generated from this template what is
this what is this template trying to
accomplish it's going to connect to the
Instagram service and it's going to use
that service to pull in the latest the
latest 10 photographs for this user
which happens to belong to Yellowstone
National Park once I get those once I
get those images I'm going to run image
an image identify on them if you saw the
keynote this morning this is the warm
language function that's been trained on
a large corpus of known images and does
fairly good job of recognizing objects
in the images okay it says it has not
yet finished on the desktop but that's
okay so that will finish eventually on
the desktop I in the in but that's a
purely desktop resident workflow what
how do we move this how do we move this
into the cloud what one would like is
the ability to sort of upload that
template have it persist in the cloud
and then whenever I wanted a report
based on that template be able to sort
of tickle it or tell it to go and then
it would communicate with whatever data
sources it needed to oh here we finished
you would communicate with whatever data
sources that need to you would need to
generate the document and then deliver
it to people I wanted I would want to
get that document all right so let's see
what that document looks like on the
desktop all right so this just went out
to Instagram it pulled in the latest 10
photos that had been posted by
Yellowstone National Park and ran image
identify on them and we're able to
identify things like stags Hot Springs
bison coniferous trees folders teasel
that's impressive if it's true I don't
know image image identified calm is very
fun to play with if you if you haven't
seen it yet this is a mash-up using
using an external service and that
built-in function so to get this thing
up into the cloud you use this magical
Cloud deploy function and you build a
construct called the document generator
this is typically a long one liner you
specify a template in this case the one
we were just looking at and then various
options like like who you want this this
this report to be delivered to and in
what format okay so I already have one
of these things deployed it's already
sitting up there in the cloud I'm going
to ask for a fresh instance of it right
now okay so this is going off and asking
the public cloud to run that report and
I'm going to check my inbox before the
end of the talk and hopefully it will
have arrived and i can i can show you
this thing having actually worked in the
meantime I'm going to show you the
results of a previous run here it is
okay so now we're in the browser this is
in the cloud this is a result of a
previous runner of that same document
generator using that same template okay
and you can see it looks like it looks
for all practical purposes identical and
that's because it is all right but this
being in the cloud now this being in a
browser it's shareable by a link okay so
this thing is no longer trapped on your
desktop it
out there in the world okay let's take a
look at another template here's one we
worked up to do some simple analytics on
tweets okay so this one is going to use
the Twitter service to look for the past
500 tweets containing token this is
called the template slot you can fill it
with whatever you want to when you're
generating the report it's going to
default to the string Wolfram okay and
we can deploy it in the same way using
the same cloud deploy I've done that I i
will ask in fact i will go back to my
presentation here and ask for a fresh
instances that report and hopefully that
will show up to in my inbox before the
talk is over and in the meantime i can
show you the results of a previous run
okay so here's here's the result of a
previous run using that using that
template and generating a report so
these are the past 500 tweets in the
world that contain the string Wolfram
it's not guaranteed that they have
anything to do with our company but this
this template does sentiment analysis on
the on the tweets using the built-in
classifier function and we can see
they're mostly indifferent but we're
happy to see this the happiest outweigh
the sads by two to one or so and then we
have a push pin map of where the tweets
originated now interestingly the the
Twitter service does not report the
latitude and longitude of where the
tweets came from you have to infer that
from the user self-reported location and
we we back a latitude and longitude out
of that using interpreter which is one
of the functions that came out of the
that came out of the the the Wolfram
Alpha integration with with the
technology stack so this is a case where
we're totally unstructured data has has
enabled us to make a very definite map
of where the tweets are coming from and
here's that same data aggregated by
country and turned into a Geo region
plot
and so on I'll just show you a couple
more templates that do very similar
things all right so here's a here's a
template that I worked up to analyze my
house utilities usage so I keep my
utilities data in an online spreadsheet
and Google Docs makes it very easy to
publish these things as publicly if you
want them to be public they can be
public publicly readable CSVs which then
you can you can slurp and do whatever
you want with so this template is going
to do some very simple time series
analysis and visualization and a little
bit of forecasting so when I deploy this
using the same cloud deploy in the same
document generator and I and I tell it
to run I get a report that looks like
this not that one this one okay alright
so this gray blob you see here is a
semantically imported data set that
contains the data from that online
spreadsheet things that look like dates
in that spreadsheet have been
automatically turned into computable
data objects things that look like money
in that spreadsheet have been turned
into computable financial quantities and
so on I didn't have to do any of this
manually so that takes a lot of the
sting out of the the sort of the nuts
and bolts part of data science and then
this data set is available for
subsequent queries and operations here's
here's a time series of my let's say the
green trace is my gas usage your enjoin
is my electricity usage these two peaks
are the past two polar vortex winters
here's some here's some attempts to look
at summer versus winter usage here's
some forecasting so here's my total
utilities bill electricity plus gas and
then I use time series model fit with an
autoregressive model to to forecast this
out for six months to see what it looks
like I don't have any cycles here so
this is kind of a toy but nevertheless I
hope this is correct and we're not
looking at another 2014
here's an example of a template that
queries the Wolfram data drop so he data
drop is this is this general purpose
data accumulator Stephen Wolfram
mentioned it in the keynote this morning
it's especially handy for devices
connected devices and sensors any
readings they take they can dump into a
data bin in data drop and they're
subsequently available offline for
offline analysis so in our case we took
one of these electric imp devices and we
put it in our break room fridge and
periodically it measures the light level
and the temperature and it drops the
data in a database and it's been making
a giant time series since since last
April and this this template pulls and
pulls in some one day's worth of data
from the time series when you deploy
this and you run it you get a report
that looks like this ok so here's one
day of data from the electric imp in the
break room fridge the blue trace is the
temperature in the orange one is the
light level these oscillations you see
here are the compressor cycling and when
it gets crazier here this is when people
are opening and closing the fridge and
there there's some heuristics in this
report to try and determine when the
fridge is open based on correlations
between the light level in the
temperature and these red zones are in
places where in principle you might want
to issue an alarm that the fridge
doesn't open too long ok so this thing
is now it's automated right it's in the
cloud and you can have this run in every
hour if you want to so you can see the
beginnings you or even even even more
often than than that if you have a
private cloud so you can see the
beginnings of how a monitoring system
based on this technology would work the
sensor itself can be very stupid all the
brains can live in the cloud and could
be tweaks whatever you want
I'll show you one more along these lines
the city of Chicago has very excellent
publicly available analytics they have
data sets on all kinds of things this
template is designed to pull in data
from there from their crime database
which goes back i think too 2001 it's
it's a totally public and totally open
so we can get it with a straight import
here and then we're going to do some
time series analysis and some mapping on
on the data in this data set this data
set is already very structured and very
clean so we don't even have to do any
semantics semantics importation on it
when we deploy this template and we run
it we get a report that looks like like
this okay so here's the past fifty
thousand reported crimes in Chicago so
this goes back to the late summer this
is aggregated by our so these
oscillations you see our daily if you
blow this up to one week you get a plot
that looks like this okay and then if
you ask what is the what is the mean
number of crimes per hour by hour of the
day you get you get a histogram that
looks like this where it's quietest
around five or six in the morning and
then it's about twice that in the
evening here's a sample of I think a
thousand a push pin map of a thousand of
the crime scenes in that in that for
months sample or so overlaid on a map of
Chicago this is using Geographics and
then you can you can do a smooth Colonel
distribution estimation based on those
based on those incidents to generate a
map like this and possibly identify
hotspots I'm not sure this is it I'm not
sure this is actually I don't think this
has any content this is probably just
showing you population density or
something but it's it's um it's in any
case it's very easy to work up things
like this
and okay so here's here's a real world
example on that you know the previous
five were sort of demos this couple
weeks ago in New York I met a guy who
worked in the financial industry and he
he he takes data mostly from from
Bloomberg about bonds and he prepares
reports about he prepares debt profiles
on these bond series for other people in
the financial industry this is not I
don't know anything about the the the
domain here but as a reporting problem
is is it was reasonably straightforward
his source data is CSVs and they're not
very big so no problem there you know
any anybody and anything can handle that
he for his output he wants recent
presentation quality PDFs that he can
email the people he wants the process to
be totally cloud resident so he never
has to babysit this is not something he
wants to have to do on his laptop he
just wants to have it up there you know
running and he wants to be able to drive
the entire process from code and we love
to hear that that's that's exactly what
we want to hear okay so the data itself
looks like looks like this it's just a
big table a couple of big tables this is
totally meaningless to me but meaningful
to people in the financial industry so
the user wrote code he wrote his own
package to take apart that data take the
fields that he wanted compute metrics of
interest to him predictions and so on
and then output these in another data
set and here I'll run that code right
now okay so his intermediate output is a
data set that looks like this that
contains all the things he's interested
in and he wants to turn this into a PDF
report that with you know that looks
nice and is nicely structured so he has
some further code that divides us up
into that groups this by Bond series and
at that point you can template this and
and you can temp like this and turn it
into a report and deploy it using using
the same mechanisms that we saw in the
previous five examples this one is is
slightly more grown up and it does a few
more things it has fancy things like an
epilogue function that sets the print
options on the generated documents so
you have a nice header and footer in
your in your PDF this example is also
slightly more complicated because the
user has code he has his own package we
have to upload that to the cloud and
make sure that's accessible in a place
where the template can get on it when it
actually
runs okay but nevertheless it you can
run this and it works I'll show you a
here's an example of what a generated
document looks like in the cloud I'll
blow this up a bit ok again this is
meaningless to me but this is this is um
this is legit as far as he's concerned
okay and the template that generates
this looks like looks like this so the
template itself is very short but it
iterates over these various series to
generate that long thing okay and and I
will show you the PDF that got dropped
in my inbox yesterday when I ran this
okay so here's the PDF so this is what
he would meal this is what he would mail
to his clients so as far as that that
problem in its requirements are
concerned he's able to do it completely
using one document generator in our
cloud so as I was gratifying the next
step he wants to take this too is to put
a forum page in front of that so that
users can can show up choose a data set
of interest to them and then generate a
report like this one based on that data
set so that that's another level of
integration but totally doable
okay the final example that I want to
talk about is is is an interesting one
and I won't be able to get all the way
through it this is a this is a request
that came from a prospective customer
their task their job consisted of doing
linear optimizations all the time on
constraints that we're constantly
changing so linear linear optimization
problem would be like I'm a farmer I
have so many acres I have so many
gallons of fertilizer and so many
gallons of pesticide I can plant corn or
beans corn and beans have a certain
price this year how do I plant my field
to maximize my income okay so that that
it's that kind of problem there's a
substantially more complicated than that
but that's the basic skeleton of it they
wanted to build an application that
their their users who are typically
agents out in the field would be able to
access so they wanted to store the
constraints in a database they wanted
these remote agents to be able to access
that database using something like a
phone or a tablet app to add constraints
to the database and then request
optimization solutions from based on the
current contents of the database okay so
this is an interesting example in a few
ways it's it's not really a report based
workflow for one thing and it also it
uses databases also it uses databases
which are typically not open to the
public we typically they're not exposed
to the outside world you can still you
can still you can still use a
cloud-based workflow to get at them but
typically you would want to do this with
a private cloud which is hosted on your
organization's internet or you know
behind a firewall someplace where it's
safe to get out that that private data
source okay and further they were
interested in visualizing the the
solutions to the solutions in
visualizing their optimizations in such
a way that they could play with them and
see what the effects of having sub
optimal solutions were so in this case
here's here's an example of minimizing
the quantity x + 2 y subject to a bunch
of constraints the way you get at this
in the war from languages with this
linear linear programming function and
there's the solution and there is X plus
2i given that solution and here's that
solution visualized okay if you saw if
you saw a yawn and john stockett at at
one o'clock getting these visualizations
like this into the cloud is as easy as
just cloud deploying them
so the same manipulate that you just saw
on my desktop will also work in the
cloud after I've deployed it although it
may take a minute to pop in or more
there it is
okay so here it is in the web browser
with interactivity intact
okay so for those of you who do have
data flows and I suspect there many of
you that talked to databases and want to
know how the Wolfram Wolfram Tecna how
this like data science stack can
interact with those databases and how to
build an application where people people
using API functions and form functions
can talk to that database I encourage
you to seek me out and I can I can go
through this example in more detail with
you okay so in in the first five or six
examples I showed you we had this sort
of classical reporting workflow where
your data coming in did some computation
on it and not a computable cloud
document coming out the nicest thing
about that and I think the single most
compelling feature about doing data
science in the cloud is that it solves
this dissemination problem of getting
getting getting data and information in
front of decision-makers in who don't
necessarily who wouldn't otherwise have
access to the data to the data analysis
tool set and that's that's very very
useful you saw me in this talk flipping
back and forth between cloud and and
desktop a lot that hybrid workflow is is
not only supported it works very well
and as and turns out to be very powerful
we saw a couple examples of
knowledge-based analytics helping us out
examples of that would be like the
interpreter interpreter function in the
Twitter template which was able to infer
tweet tweet-tweet locations for us based
on unstructured data semantic
interpretation was able to clean up our
utility spreadsheet with no work on our
part the private clouds in the database
example that I wasn't able to go through
thoroughly our fur are appropriate for
data sources that you don't want to or
can't expose to the public we are
working on a Wolfram data science
platform that will sort of streamline
the kinds of things that you've seen
here and particularly the problem of
working with multiple documents in a
single browser tab is a very thorny
design and technological problem so you
might have a template and a report
generated by that template and possibly
some other code to that you need to be
editing at the same time so the data
science platform will be designed to
make that easier but i want to emphasize
that everything you've seen here
and is doable with the current cloud and
was done with the current cloud so that
if any of this looks interesting you're
useful you can start tinkering
immediately